[MUSIC PLAYING]
YEN-JIE LEE: 8.03 is a very,
very interesting course,
because without
waves and vibrations
we will not be able to even
recognize this universe.
Doing this class, I decided
to include a lot of demos
during my lectures.
Demonstrations are
particularly useful,
because we first introduce
the physical situation
we are interested.
Then we compare our
mathematical solution
to reality, which is
actually the demo.
I hope you will be able to
enjoy this free content provided
by OCW, including
the lecture videos,
the lecture notes, and
the problem solving video
from Professor Wit Busza.
Yeah, it's really cool.
You'll take the course, right?